my name is Adam Bello I'm a book editor
at HarperCollins and I'm the editor of a
new book published by the Templeton
Press called new threats to freedom
it wasn't until I sat down and read the
whole stack of essays from beginning to
end that I began to see some patterns
one of the one of the recurring themes
for example is the concern about the
abuse of the idea of fairness this was
something that has been bothering me you
know ever since the Obama election
because we're constantly being told that
you know that we need more fairness and
so I you know I did explicitly ask one
or two people that to tackle this idea
and other people just spontaneously went
there on their own so it does seem to me
that this is one of those you know one
of those buzzwords that has entered into
the public lexicon that that whose
content really needs to be unpacked and
critically examined
so that was one thread that runs through
the through the book but I think taken
as a whole
the thing that I like about the
collection is its idiosyncrasy the fact
that it's a collection of essays by
people who are very distinct in their
way of thinking and writing and
expressing themselves they typically
don't belong to any school of thought I
was I particularly went out of my way to
commissioned pieces from literary
authors people like Mark Halperin the
novelist David Mamet the playwright
Shelby Steele who was somebody I
consider to be a literary intellectual
though he doesn't produce literature
because I because I've always felt that
that the literary mind has a sort of
breadth of humane concern that we don't
often find in the precincts of an
ideological shop
the more successful we've been as a
civilization the more the more we tend
to as Machiavelli would say we mistake
our our good luck for our virtue and
strength there's a there's a tendency to
to think well we came out on top because
it was somehow destined our history is
on our side or you know we're number one
where we're the best and you know I
think we have to take seriously always
the the admonition of our founders that
Liberty is our own individual burden
privilege and responsibility the
generation that that I refer to as the
grown-ups the generation of my father
Solzhenitsyn the the the great figures
of the Cold War the intellect of
intellectual heroes of the Cold War the
people that I admired and looked up to
when I was a when I was a young book
editor that those people are gone now
and I did and I did feel as i canta came
to feel as i was putting this collection
together that I was looking to sort of
you know replace them in some way we I
felt that we needed to step up as a
generation to this challenge of reviving
a discourse about freedom and democracy
but I wanted it to be also different in
the sense that you know my perception of
you know what it was like to sit around
the dinner table with people like you
know my father and and his friends was
somewhat gloomy you know perhaps because
the threat of nuclear annihilation was
you know was always hanging over us and
there was that there was that sense of
urgency of ultimate stakes I don't feel
that the United States is in danger of
being you know annihilated
for example but i but i do feel that we
have an opportunity and an obligation as
a generation to revive this concern this
traditional concern with freedom but
that we we can also do it in a way
that's more consistent with our temper
as a generation we are we're more I
think you know comfortable with popular
culture there's a lot more levity in our
in our generation and so I wanted the
our way of embracing these issues to be
a little less doer and grim and a little
more upbeat more fun the defense of
freedom should be fun
you